die budgeerhöhung für unser Bundesheer
ist finalisiert
was nun mit den zusätzlichen
Finanzmitteln für das Bundesheer
passieren soll möchte ich Ihnen in der
nächsten Minuten präsentieren mein Name
ist Bruno Günther Hofbauer ich bin der
planungschef des österreichischen
Bundesheeres
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat uns in den
letzten Monaten vor Augen geführt wie
rasch sich auch hier in Europa die Lage
ändern kann wie gefährlich es schnell
werden kann und welchem Wert es hat
militärische Landesverteidigung wieder
ernst zu nehmen der streitkräfteprofil
unser Herr wird nun in die Umsetzung
gekommen im generalstaat wurde in den
letzten Monaten intensiv Bearbeitungen
vorgenommen um einen Aufbauplan für das
Bundesheer 2032 zu erstellen ja Sie
haben richtig gehört 2032 denn es wird
zehn Jahre dauern zumindest um die
Fähigkeiten die notwendig sind um den
Konflikt der Zukunft bestehen zu können
in das Bundesheer wieder hinein zu
bekommen
hier geht es um die Stärkung des
Kernbereichs des Bundesheeres um die
militärische Landesverteidigung
dazu brauchen wir nicht nur motivierte
und best-
eine adäquate und zeitgemäße
Infrastruktur im Kasernen für unsere
Ausbildung und für ihre
Einsatzvorbereitung
sondern es geht natürlich auch um die
Ausrüstung
im Kern des aufbauplans stehen drei
Bereiche Mobilität der Einsatzkräfte
Schutz und Wirkung für unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sowie Autarkie
und Nachhaltigkeit
kommen wir zum ersten Bereich der
Mobilität
bei der Mobilität werden wir unter
anderem die bereits vorhandene
pandurflotte erweitern und ausbauen und
so geschützten Transportraum für unsere
Soldaten im In- und Ausland zur
Verfügung stellen
wir werden Transportfahrzeuge aller Art
in alle Waffengattungen des Bundesheeres
integrieren die Pioniere bekommen
beispielsweise moderne pionierpanzer und
neue Fähren aber es geht auch um leichte
umgepanzerte Fahrzeuge für unser
Jagdkommando bzw die leichte Infanterie
aber Mobilität ist nicht nur am Boden
sondern auch in der Luft
die betagte C130 die mehr als 50 Jahre
bereits im Dienst steht muss abgelöst
werden durch ein neues Transportflugzeug
die hubschrauberflotte muss weiter
modernisiert werden und natürlich muss
unser Kampfflugzeug der Eurofighter
dorthin gebracht werden wo er hingehört
er muss in der Nacht
entsprechend für den Einsatz
bereitstehen und seine vollen
Fähigkeiten als modernes Kampfflugzeug
nutzen können dem Kernbereich des
aufbauplans
dem bildet allerdings Schutz und Wirkung
für unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten für
unsere Einsatzkräfte hier geht es um
persönliche Ausrüstung um einen
adäquaten individualschutz um die
Fähigkeit in der Nacht sehen und kämpfen
zu können und moderne
Kommunikationsmittel und natürlich auch
um zeitgemäße präzise Einsatzmittel und
Kampfmittel für die Aufklärungstruppe
werden Sensoren aller Art beschafft
werden und in allen Domänen sprechen
Land Luft im cyberraum aber auch im
informationsumfeld ein Lagebild zur
Verfügung zu haben und
führungsüberlegenheit herstellen zu
können
wir nehmen natürlich auch die
Bedrohungen aus der Luft sehr ernst hier
geht es nicht nur um Abwehr von Drohnen
sondern es geht um einen Mix es geht
darum drohnenabwehr
Nutzung vorhandener Systeme die
entsprechend Kampfwert gesteigert werden
aber auch Ausbau der Reichweite für das
Bundesheer und seine ungebundene
Luftverteidigung auf 40 km oder mehr der
Krieg an der Ukraine hat uns aber auch
gezeigt
dass mechanisierte Truppen nicht der
Vergangenheit angehören dass sie nach
wie vor ihre Rolle auf dem Gefechtsfeld
haben mechanisierte Kräfte Kampfpanzer
Schützenpanzer Artillerie allerdings
kampfwertgesteigert für den moderne
Konfliktsituation ausgelegt mit
präzisionswirkungen und entsprechenden
Schutzgrad somit werden wir auch die
mechanisierten Kräfte des Bundesheeres
insgesamt entsprechend erneuern
das alles hilft aber nichts wenn wir
nicht üben denn was wir nicht üben das
können wir nicht und somit wird
natürlich für alle Teile des
Bundesheeres sei es das Kader sei es die
Milz und natürlich auch die Rekruten in
die verstärkte Übungstätigkeit des
Bundesheeres zu investieren sein nun zum
dritten Kernbereich für den Aufbauplan
2032 Autarkie und Nachhaltigkeit
das Bundesheer muss funktionieren wenn
sonst nichts mehr funktioniert dazu
braucht es autarke Kasernen die in der
Lage sind unsere Truppen entsprechend zu
versorgen und zu schützen wir brauchen
die Versorgungsgüter in ausreichender
Menge dass wir den Einsatz bestehen
können und wir brauchen eine
hochqualifizierte Sanitätsversorgung und
wir werden uns auch daran orientieren
müssen die
energieversorgungsabhängigkeit von außen
zu reduzieren auf dem modernen gefächts
fehlt ist der Kampf im Cyberspace und
auch der Electronic warfare-bereich
nicht wegzudenken und somit wird auch
hier entsprechend zu investieren sein in
Hardware aber auch in der entsprechende
Ausbildung unseres Personals die
Digitalisierung die Nutzung moderner
Kommunikations- und
Informationstechnologie bildet die
Klammer über alle Anstrengungen für den
Aufbauplan 2032 denn das ermöglicht uns
schneller zu sein als der Gegner
das Bundesheer ist stark im Inland und
fokussiert im Ausland gehen wir es
gemeinsam an es wird ein langer
aufwendiger Weg werden aber nutzen wir
die verfügbare Zeit